Greta vanberg has been convicted of
disobeying police during a protest
against the oil industry in Sweden the
20 year old climate activist was
detained last month in the port city of
Malmo she was ordered to pay a 240 fine
dunberg and other activists were
arrested after they stopped traffic at
an oil terminal Al jazeera's Paul Reese
spoke to her after the sentencing
Greta tunberg arrived at the court just
before 11 30 a.m Swedish time when her
trial was due to start shadowed by
national and international media every
step of her way up to the courtroom now
the judges decided that for disobeying
police orders to stop blocking oil
tanker trucks leaving the oil Harbor
here in Malmo on June the 19th she
should be given a fine of about 150 US
dollars plus costs avoiding what could
have been a six-month prison sentence
she told me afterwards that despite the
low level of the fine the law needed to
be more on the side of climate activists
like herself and less on the side of
companies that she says are contributing
to The Climate crisis
we are in this specific case we were
some young people who first stood up
against the fossil fuel industry and
then we stood up against the judicial
system and we and we
were quite alone in this fight we need
many many more people as it is now I
think more and more people are starting
to see the episode of The Office of the
situation that short-term economic
profits are worth more than our
Collective future and that our laws as
they are now are not made for protecting
people long term against the
self-destructing
greed that we have
let's take full control over the world
but rather the laws that we have right
now are protecting destructive
Industries and companies who are killing
the planet and killing people
well immediately after that interview
Greta tunberg left the court in Malmo
went back to the oil Harbor sat down
again and blocked oil tanker trucks from
leaving
recommencing the protest that got her in
court in the first place the police
again told her she had to get out of the
way she stayed there and was eventually
dragged away uh her and her fellow
activists are now gathered here to
regroup at the end of the day and plot
their next move whatever that may be
Paul Reese Al Jazeera malmer